ja das stimmt da was echt gut ich will
aber auch ich bin
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft games zusammen mit dem
hier hallo hallo ich bin die räume oder
raum wo wir gerade sind sieht anders aus
als der in ihrer vollen leute die jetzt
von gomez folge kommen und dann wir
weiter schauen wollen heute die denken
sich erst mal was machen die denn da die
sache ist ich glaube sogar wenn man den
sockel abbaut
da ist darunter ihr seht eine redstone
schalter da drunter ist auf jeden fall
irgendwo das mit den kuchen was wir in
der letzten folge gemacht haben
allerdings habt ihr schon gemerkt da
waren ca 40 sprüngen die man machen
musste wir haben die ersten fünf
hingekriegt weil er so wenig gekommen
ich bin total überbelichtet erzählte was
der grund ist warum wir jetzt gedacht
haben dass wir das ganze mal ganz kurz
überspringen
also der punkt war dabei einfach der
dass werth gemerkt haben und uns das
einfach die sprünge extrem schwierig
wirklich sind und dann noch wirklich wir
eigentlich an sich noch zwei folgen
mindestens bestimmt für gebraucht hätten
wenn wir es überhaupt geschafft hätten
denn der turm wo die kuchen so hoch
gestapelt waren
wenn ihr es gesehen habe vielleicht beim
medium ist wirklich verdammt hoch er ist
verdammt unfassbar hoch das hat so
unglaublich lange gedauert bis man das
wirklich mal geschafft hätte einmal das
ist echt unglaublich das ich jetzt dafür
wir nehmen uns einfach so ein bisschen
was zu fressen mit falls wir das
brauchen falls wir lange sterben oder
ich weiß gar nicht ob von braun ist egal
ob du bist du schön bei dir jedes in
schalter ja genau hier können wir dann
weg zum spot
das heißt wir sind jetzt hier bei bei
level 2 kommt er jetzt ne
weiß welche schwierigkeit mario ist wie
kulti hart nein nein aber man im forum
richtig episch aus die karte an sich wir
haben gesagt ja difficulty hat nur am
anfang jetzt die platzwahl ein letter
darauf leider drauf da wurde darf die
schnee ich bin mario ich wollte nicht
gewartet du musst da draufdrücken auf
dem level bin mario ich sehe wirklich
aus wie mario ja doch stimmt wie schön
du bist ein bisschen unsichtbar bin noch
neben dir glaub ich mal ganz kurz aus
wir bringen das ganze damit wir euch
nicht antun müssen ist die idee auf
anderen seiten stehen congratulations da
müssen wir denn das heißt einmal die
ganze richtung spielen aber das sieht
nicht so schwer aus
ich finde das auch dass ich bin weiter
wir beim kuchen level
wahrscheinlich habe noch kein schicksal
haben aber ich schaffe das gerade also
das heißt ich habe das gerade ich bin
jetzt paar sprünge walter hamann wird
von pfeile abgeschossen von irgendwo
glaube ich und wie es wohl habe ich
finde das nicht schwer ich auch nicht
bisher halt einfach dein maul du dein
maul als mannschaft panik weil sonst
kommen gleich die schwierigen sprünge
und jetzt merkt man schon
das schafft mal gar nicht ich lass dich
mal vor du musst von dem unteren sprung
ab ja ja gut so warte hier oben drauf
drin wie wir sie ist einfach zwei stücke
cool ich habe jetzt insgesamt fünf
stücke kohle
ich habe sieben ja aber nicht doch
wesentlich
der 2 sport ist sicher auch nur zu mir
tut mir leid euch zu machen
naja stimmt du bist immer wieder beim
dings ich war ja genau ich mal runter
und dann bin ich beim kuchen
ich schaff das einfach am laufenden band
oder das respekt ich hab gedacht das ist
genau mein level hier
das ist hier unten ach guck mal hier
sobald holzkohle drin in den spendern
also ich weiß nicht ob holzkohle
irgendwas einem bringen nachher oder ob
das so tobias ich springe hier alles
nicht alles weitere und jetzt was ist
jetzt
ich habe zehn stück holzkohle wohlauf
märz lang
wir können nur sterben wir können nur
sterben quatsch nicht hier mal so
pessimistisch denken kommt noch nicht
lange
ich hab ein kuchen noch kann ich mich
damit einem buch ist hacken ich habe
leider den gesetzt vielleicht setzen wir
gucken einer wand geht als man
vielleicht unter mich nicht auch nicht
ob man ich habe da könnte ich hier hoch
schwinden ja ich hab es geschafft ich
wissen über ihr alter das kanalisation
war ich mache ich wirklich kommen zu dir
einfach die sein dass wir einfach kein
check point haben die sachen wieder kein
check point und sagt mir lieber wo wir
lag jetzt lang müssen hier komm ich
schlag dich und dann du läufst du nicht
einfach hier und dann einfach schwimmen
ich kann sich daher aus boxen lassen
wir kommen nicht hoch wie soll man denn
sonst verlangt ich habe ehrlich hoch
nicht hoch doch muss nur spring spring
ich springe die ganze zeit
du musst doch jetzt auch mal hier nein
ich weniger zeit glaube ich bedroht
solange müssen
santana ich sage nicht ich sagte nicht
da sagte ich sag's nicht das ganze nicht
wir aber wahrscheinlich starben
axel ist schön
nur träumen
ja du ich hab's ja auch stimmt schon das
gericht wie wirst du dir ich darf das
dafür halte ich meine ganzen richtig
abgeräumt
ja das stimmt da was echt gut ich will
lieber direkt hier drüber ich glaub sehr
wohl nicht
ich spring überlegt ich bin bei den
kuchen fällt sich über eine kugel
ich glaube die harten level
das hatte auch mit die spore punkte die
es da kaum gibt ja auch ein mann wie
soll man da hingekommen war es einfach
mal zwei betten mitnehmen da gehe ich
kurz den game mode 1 das sonst vorne
dann spawn setzen
ich fasse es nicht ich fasse es echt
nicht was ist hier los
weil ich was ist los mit dir
armstrong sah so ich drücke jetzt
erstmal knopf ist brasilien wie zwei
betten auf für uns weil hier mal ganz
schick
81 dann mach ich mal ganz kurz vorher
die betten hier eigentlich
übrigens ein sehr tolles thema gerade
von peter welche waffe würdet ihr bei
einer zombie apokalypse ja auch nicht
von debitor also ich dass ich für dich
nehmen ja gut das ist aber unser einzige
tag an den wir jetzt haben aber es ist
ein bisschen scheiße eigentlich wenn wir
dann quasi weiter springen die ganze
zeit und dann können wir hier müssen wir
einfach wieder porten
das wäre wichtig sind was liebe ist kein
zuckerschlecken
ich schaffe hier wieder alles menschen
die sam lowes mit ihr
der regen aufgehört habt ihr manchmal
keinen bock videos zu dem zu machen was
anderes thema wo bin ich
du bist ich kann darunter ja also es ist
natürlich es ist ist natürlich immer so
ja man denkt sich ja geil ist super geil
dass wir das halt machen weil es halt
mega spaß macht aber es gibt natürlich
manchmal momente wo ich mir sage ich zum
beispiel wenn man krank ist oder so
dabei an den moment macht man halt auch
keine videos deswegen hab ich halt
gesagt das ist ein hobby das mache ich
nur wenn es mir spaß macht also wenn ich
gerade in dem moment lust drauf habe
deswegen kamen bei mir zum beispiel
einen monat lang einfach mal keine
videos weil ich mir gesagt haben
zurzeit habe ich keine lust darauf
irgendwie das spiel zu spielen aber
mittlerweile habe ich wieder total bock
deswegen machen wir es ja auch wie ich
glaube wir uns nicht machen wir keinen
spaß machen würde
bei jedem hobby ist es mal so dass man
sagt ich wollte immer mal tage wo man
sich sagten die keinen bock gerade wenn
man einfach chaos oder sogar zum
beispiel gestern habe ich sechs videos
aufgenommen und das war alles
danach so ein bisschen zu viel meinen
meine stimme war total trocken meine
meine lippen bahn ein bisschen
entfeuchtet weil man ja zum reden war
und deswegen ist das halt ein bisschen
man wird er durch angeschlagen
das weiß nicht wie ich das sagen soll
also wenn man dann längst wieder sicher
erfolge hat jetzt aufnehmen ich schaffe
den ersten sprüngen
aber wenn man dann so zehn videos
hintereinander aufgenommen sondern so
ein projekt oder so dann dann denkt man
sich so born ich könnte sich noch ein
video aufnimmt ko soll ja genau das ist
genauso wie mit fußball wenn ihr lust
auf fußball habe dann spielt der fußball
so lang dass ihr total ausgepowert zeit
und dann könnt ihr auch nicht mehr
stimmt aber so macht es total spaß bei
dir sehr wichtig für uns sagt er genauso
das passt eigentlich völlig auch auf
mich und wenn ich irgendwie keinen bock
aber so habe oder halt wirklich mir mal
etwas nicht spaß macht wo ich auch finde
okay es macht keinen spaß dann sage ich
es auch irgendwie es ist wenn werde ich
jetzt schon in letzter zeit oft verfolgt
da habe ich auch manchmal eine videos
gesagt irgendwie ja eigentlich gerade
die runde weiß ich nicht geht so eng wie
vor eigentlich weiß nicht ich hatte
jetzt gerade vor vor kurzem englisch
gespielt glaube ich was waren das was
war anders da habe ich mir auch gesagt
ich nehme das auf was ich möchte das war
zum beispiel beim großen simulator hängt
wieder sehr hart ich habe ich auch
gedacht darauf habe ich bock gerade mal
heute vielleicht kein minecraft video
aber dafür hat margot simulator lg emma
die leidenschaft ist natürlich immer
noch so sag ich mal videospiele zu
spielen
minecraft und so und dabei halt spaß zu
haben aber manchmal geht es halt immer
mal taro aso sein kann man sich sagen ja
eher weniger lust am rand meistens hat
man ja vielleicht auch für die tage
schon was vor produziert dann passt es
schon
ich habe gerade einen block aus versehen
kaputt gemacht ich habe aus versehen und
ich muss enttäuscht da unten felder
felder der crafter dennis hecht musste
bittet linien tja es ist ein paar
umstände die halt immer passen müssen
zum beispiel auch ich hab letztes
survival games gespielt hab ich da mal
nicht umbenannten mit fünf leuten teilen
her drei wollten einem mir als sachen
geben und die anderen zwei sind da noch
die anderen aufgegangen das ist keine
games mich das macht natürlich keinen
spaß weil das wandelt man wird verfolgt
und steht dann direkt und das bei über
acht runden und sitzt man sitzt dann
hängen wir eine stunde an einer runde sv
will game soll noch viel länger manchmal
nur weil man immer meine anderen
rundenende verfolgt wurde selbst
angelegt wirkt der erde gelegt ist dann
wird man ja auch noch teilweise manchmal
kärnten das ist ja weil leute schreiben
ist derweil
dann gucken sie den chat genau die
person gar nichts geschrieben und so ja
da gibt es ein paar spezialisten die
dann bei wissen aber letztendlich macht
es spaß aber die umstände müssen stimmig
sag's mal so also die umstellt ist
einfach man muss fit sein
man muss halt gerade gute laune haben
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel gerade eine
4 wieder bekomme wenig im fach dann habe
ich keine lust irgendwie video zu machen
weil ich dann deprimiert drauf bin
aber jetzt halt ja also für die vier gut
ist dann nein aber ich sowas immer alles
schillig 4
schillig sehen einfach nächstes mal
besser machen irgendwie dann läuft das
sage ich jetzt arbeite aber auch ich
muss jetzt auch zwei abi klausuren
schreiben also eine abi klausur muss
noch schreiben und eine muss noch
sprechen dass eines matte das kann ich
aber eigentlich und das andere ist sowie
das wirtschaft das thema in motto
irgendwie eins von den themen funktion
integral funktionen
das klingt geil das wasser noch also ich
hab das nicht zu viel dafür gelernt muss
man überlegen was steht noch alles im
curriculum polynorm division fällt
einfach oder so ja ich denke zwei oder
so müsste das ist halt mündlich matte
mündlichen damit so endlich scheiße
vorstellen wir haben so eine brühe wir
sind so eine prüfung mal durchgegangen
wir uns im kurs ist halt wirklich so du
kriegst eine klausur rechtens die eine
halbe stunde draußen dabei gucken wir
drei lehrer zug damit du nicht sprichst
das ist richtig krass ich kann das gar
nicht wenn lehrer hinter mir steht und
mir dann über die schulter gucken was
mache ich denke für falsch man rechnet
eine halbe stunde eine klausur man muss
seine lösungen vorstellen von den
lehrern die zuhören da fällt man zehn
minuten zeit und damit man zehn minuten
lang abgefragt das heißt und man geht
dann gefragt ja wie hättest du das und
das denn sonst noch ausrechnen können
oder ja wie genau
berechnet man denn die länge einer
brache funktion mit anwendungen von
vektoren oder irgendwie ein schals und
dann muss man das den halt antworten ja
es klingt ja total einfach und so wird
es eine einfach als das so durchgegangen
sind hat einfach eine geweint weil sie
nichts konnte echten anja hat dann wird
sondern übergangen und ohne deswegen
auch gedacht beste taktik einfach weiter
dann haben die mitleid mit dir du hast
gut kulig hat gefunden habe
17 als ob wo bist du ich bin etwas
weiter noch ich bin jetzt an der hälfte
in etwa angekommen weiter als ich vorhin
war ja jump into the water und jetzt
habe ich glaube ich ein problem weil ich
jetzt nicht weiter weiß ich bin
irgendwie so falle wieder gelandet
ich bin ein geschätztes unterwegs und
ich bedroht ja man das gefällt mir das
gefällt mir nicht anders wenn man so tot
ist oder das ist immer sehr sehr eben
verdammt ich muss hier die map grad so
ein bisschen zerstören damit ich hier
auf so ein paar dinge wieder hochkommen
jetzt geht das ja alles gar nicht juni
macht die map kaputt ja ich weiß wir
dürfen das eigentlich gar nicht aber
sonst muss ich halt wieder ihr nicht von
vorne aber halt alles das ist dann so
ein bisschen scheiße verdammt schon
wieder so ne verdammt soll ich jetzt
habe ich das schon wieder hier kacke
gemacht beim ein tor noch ein bisschen
lauter gott bist du noch da ich bin auch
da ein bisschen vollstes konzentriert
nahm ich lerne ich grad bei twitter nach
themen und lässt so die theorie du schon
irgendwie wie vor einer halben stunde
gestellt hast bist du jungfrau wollte
oder oder seid ihr schon mal vom zehn
meter turm gesprungen oder aber was man
hat hier alles was du halt schon
vorgelegen
aber irgendwie habe ich hier gerade kaum
team was ist ein neues mittel ein
nein ich bin da wo wir dann auch wieder
runter gefallen sind
aber das war's auch schon
da von dieser folge ich habe 18 minuten
damen und herren wir sind wir produktiv
gewesen die aber wir haben auf jeden
fall eine neue karte und ums mario
angeschaut wir sind auf jeden fall schon
fast bei der hälfte von mario und ich
denke wenn dahin ich sehe da hinten aber
schon zwei betten und die andere hälfte
das sollten wir wenn wir unsere anhalt
in der nächsten folge sollte wieder
schaffen
ich würde sagen es euch gefallen hat las
eine bewertung und sonst themen könnt
ihr wir können ihr könntet beiden bei
twitter folgen
da ja toll da geht es immer um tibet
frage htc autos und schönen tag ich bin
tot
mit